the White House says history shows the
Congressional Budget Office is quote
totally incapable of predicting the
Republican health care bills impact a
new CBO report shows the bill to replace
Obamacare reduces federal deficit by 119
billion dollars over the next 10 years
but it also leaves 23 million more
people uninsured Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning you might remember that House
Republicans move to pass their Obamacare
replacement bill the minute that they
thought they had enough votes they did
not wait for a review from the
nonpartisan Congressional Budget Office
Democrats criticized them for it at the
time and now they've got new ammunition
call it whatever you want but please do
not call this bill a health care bill
Democrats seized on the 41 page report
which warns that under the House bill
the non group or individual market would
start to become unstable beginning in
2024 about 1/6 of the population that's
because states could get waivers that
allow insurers to set premiums that are
higher for sick people than healthy
people rates for those with pre-existing
conditions would rise over time the
report warns if they could purchase it
at all the bill is passed
analysis comes three weeks after House
Republicans passed their bill by just
one vote they were just severe so
anxious to put all these people off with
their insurance and play people in the
poor houses they just got carried away
New Jersey Republican Tom McArthur wrote
the waiver amendment that was designed
to win over weary conservatives he
questioned the new numbers this is the
same CBO that predicted that in 2016
we'd have 22 million people in the
Obamacare exchanges there were
they were off by a staggering 120% the
Congressional Budget Office also
determined that middle-aged low-income
Americans on the individual market would
see an average premium increase of eight
hundred percent because the house bills
tax credits are smaller than Obama cares
that acceptable to you it's not actually
Oklahoma Republican James Lankford
insists the Senate's version will be
much better he notes that under
Obamacare individual premiums in his
state rose nearly 70 percent last year
we've got to be able to deal with that
but we also can deal with what the house
centers right now we've got to be able
to make some Corrections the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell appeared
to lower expectations for a final Senate
bill yesterday in an interview he said
that Republican senators are meeting
behind closed doors to hash something
out but quote I don't know how we get to
50 votes at the moment north Wow Nancy
thank you so much